So now we know how to do
predicted value, right.
So the p of x t given
all our measurements.
So given this, and then we take a
measurement at time t, what do we want.
We want the new corrected value, x of t,
given y's through y t so we're folding
in the new measurement, all right.
The way we're going to do that is we're
going to make use of Bayes Rule, and I'm
just going to, I have written down here
for those of you who, don't remember
Bayes Rule and don't have it tattooed
on the, inside of your right thigh.
But here basically is what we're doing,
right?
So Bayes rule says that if I want to
know the probability of A given B,
I can flip it around by knowing
the likelihood of B given A.
And then there are these
other terms in here, okay?
And you'll notice what we did
here is we switched this around.
This is now the probability of getting
the measurement given all these
previous stuff,
times the probability, what is this?
Well, that's just our prediction,
okay, that's, that's P of A.
And then this, this is going to turn
out just to be a normalization factor.
By using our independence assumption,
right.
The independence assumption says that
our measurement y t, given x t and
all this stuff,
is only a function of, x t.
All right?
And the reason that I refer to this
bottom part as normalization is,
remember this is
a probability over here.
And basically,
they all have to sum to one.
And we'll get to that later.
And this, this bottom value
just normalizes everything so
that it sums to one.
And if you really wanted to
calculate that normalization, okay,
what you have to do is,
you have to compute all the different
possible probability of getting that y t
over all of the x t predictions
over the integral over all the x t.
But it, we are never ever going to be
sort of computing that bottom part.
That's just there so you can see what
the sort of the total integral is.
And in fact now it says
really a normalization.
So it's really, really a normalization.